للمره الاولى يعني نشهد ليله امس كان هناك
اشتباكات بين اسرائيليين من اليمين
واسرائيليين من اليسار حيث يتظاهروا اما
اليوم هناك يعني من المتوقع ان تشهد
اسرائيل مظاهره كبيره وكبيره جدا ربما
الاكبر ستكون في القدس منذ بدء المظاهرات
منذ اكثر من 12
اسبوعا ايضا هناك دعوات من قبل بنك فير
وسمبنيين ايضا الى التظاهر في الشوارع في
القدس ضد ايضا
المتظاهرين الموجودين اليوم في القدس يوجد
هنا عشرات يعني اعداد قليله حتى الان من
اليمينيين يتظاهرون مع هذه التعديلات
القضائيه يعني شاهدنا ايضا عشرات من
المتظاهرين
يؤيدون التعديلات القضائيه ويعني يوجد
هناك كان اشتباكات بين اليمين واليسار حتى
في الشارع وهذا ما لمسناه وكان هناك تدخل
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي لمحاوله فعليا فض
او وقف هذا الاشتباكات بين الطرفين في
طبيعه الامر شاهدنا او سمعنا في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي الخطاب يتحدث عن حرب اهليه او
حتى عن انقلاب عسكري ولكن الان بدنا نراه
ونشهده في الارض الواقع